oui j'ai entendu j'ai 328 l'église donc
je voulais préciser quelque chose ce
n'est pas moi qui ai fait la demande a
pour que monsieur verdez ne sera pas là
ce soir c'est l'organisation miss france
qui est bienveillante à mon égard
problèmes toi voilà
non mais je tiens à préciser parce que
depuis tout à l'heure j'ai en tant que
c'est moi donc me juge
moi je ne vous juge pas mais sachez que
c'est l'organisation miss france qui la
demandent un go alors moi moi je vous
dis moi par contre en revanche je tiens
mes promesses non mais c'est vrai je
j'ai promis à l'organisation miss france
miss et prendre que gilles quitterait le
plateau lorsque maeva serai là je leur
ai promis je sais que ma valeur vous ça
vous dérange pas en fait c'est vrai oui
mais comme ils veulent pas est-ce qu'on
alors est ce que vous pouvez lire dans
le public pour la très bien on sait un
petit kiff l'adage il voulait dire
quelque chose à bord et je voudrais dire
quelque chose mais c'est beau ce qu'elle
a fait super c'est formidable ce que
vous avez fait je regarde tous les
concours miss france et j'ai des
jugements parfois sur ce que vous dites
vous avez une autre mais cela qu'ils
n'attaquent pas du tout à l'attaqué à
cenon absolument tu n'arrives visu voilà
j'ai des jugements qui sont parfois durs
avec des choses qui me tiennent à coeur
mais ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que je suis très content que vous soyez
là je trouve formidable de discuter
parce qu'il faut toujours débattre y
compris quand on n'est pas d'accord
et quelle que soit mon opinion quelle
que soit mon opinion
vous êtes magnifique et je vous souhaite
un futur radieux en miss france et dans
votre vie d'après donc merci beaucoup
alors que brest est là pour l'instant on
va voir je vais voir là dedans un
instant jours et la décision du comité
miss france
voilà parce que il avait décrit très
bien d'accord permettent une boule dans
la bouche
en fait c'est lui qui doit sortir
franchement le comité miss france
faites moi plaisir